So, why did we start off with shapes? And why are these different categories of
2 dimensions and 3 dimensions? Well, we first looked at this overarching, or
broad category called shapes. We think of shapes as being made up of curves and
straight lines connected at points or vertices. Then we looked at how we could
find differences between those shapes, two dimensional, and three dimensional.
We were wondering, are the shapes flat or not? And, from that single question we
were able to make these two categories about our shapes. Well, this is also true
about functions. We use functions to describe particular relationships in math.
For this unit, we're going to focus on polynomials. Expressions with constants,
with linear terms, quadratic terms, or cubic terms are all considered to be part
of polynomials. Constants are numbers like 3, negative 4,or 5 halves. Linear
terms contain a single variable with an exponent of 1. We don't have to write
the 1 as the exponent, because we assume that's the case. A linear term might
have constant terms on it or not, but it's the variable with the exponent of 1
that makes it linear. Quadratic polynomials contain an x squared. And, cubic
polynomials, they contain a cube, or a third power. For this unit, we won't
focus on the graphs of polynomials. We're going to focus on working with them.
So adding subtracting multiplying and dividing them. You might be wondering what
some of these other functions are. They include square roots and exponentials,
but don't worry about these. We'll get to them later.